[Applause]
it's the time of year where you're
they're depressed because you're alone
or depressed because you're trapped in a
relationship happy Valentine's Day to
make it extra special I gave my Twitter
followers the chance to proclaim their
love on TV as long as they include one
thing they want to change about their
sweetheart in a segment called be mine
and be better I love you Kim but please
stop gossiping along in the car it makes
me want to drive in oncoming traffic
you don't gossip while your man is
driving a vehicle here's what you do you
sit there quietly and about five minutes
before you reach your destination you
say hey would you like some road head I
love you but I'm also in love with
Swedish Fish
that's my cha cha cha the smiley face I
love you Rachel but you got to stop
wearing socks to bed
Jim Rachel take off your socks it's
gross I love you Amy but I wish you knew
how to make a decent gravy
why is gravy capitalized
is that how bad her gravy is Amy has no
idea she's making subpar gravy
this guy's not asking for an excellent
gravy if I want the best gravy
he wants a decent rate so he can choke
down that dog food you call dinner this
is the harmonic kicks how I greet my
staff every morning lets them know I
still care without crossing any lines
[Music]
Ritalin sure there's no more mana
cuizeen some people just don't know how
to behave in the workplace look what's
on our door princess here's why you
never marry the baby voice girl okay
first of all you're not a princess
Jennifer princesses vacation on yachts
in the Mediterranean not at amusement
parks in Anaheim put any water my guess
is the poor pussy-whipped bastard that's
married to you wants them to die just
like this relationship spectacular
spectacular looks right now give that to
your husband so he can hang himself with
it
and here's my Ceptor it's smartly the
only way this is worth it is if that
scepter ends up in her butt later good
lord this bitch better have cancer I
don't treat my girlfriend like a
princess I treat her like a queen not
just on her birthday every day hey I
can't find my phone
we call it real quick sort of dragons
that the Queen's name shall never be
spoken my kingdom begain gone fine I'm
getting tight food for dinner you speak
with such disdain get you beg for mercy
winter is coming
if this next pillow could talk it would
be sobbing they are gonna have so many
little throw pillows that's just how you
fluff up a pillow in my house thank you
to stop keep my couch cushions because
it was always so awkward at breakfast
the next morning that pillow didn't want
it shouldn't have worn that a red
pillowcase really aggressive tonight
Cameron you sure you're not upset about
my parents in the weekend here's the
best way to keep your relationships
fresh yeah I can't watch this I get
claustrophobic if I even hold a girl's
hand now psychopath can fit five times
as many victims in their meat locker are
you guys smiling
let's put on matching white shirts and
rolled up jeans and posed in the sand
like normal love birds this is what
cannibals do with their leftovers you
need to eat or freeze them by the end of
the month I have to preserve my staff at
the end of every season but I just
pickle them alright see you guys next
season
you